someone off this [ __ ] really happy as
your brother Rob how is he doing he's
doing really good and he is on his
healthy fitness journey which I'm so
ecstatic about and I just want everyone
to be happy and healthy that's like the
golden light you got to do the journey
when it's on your time and for you you
can't do it for anybody else Khloe got
candid about her younger brother and her
own journey while hosting allergens
lifts chin up campaign in NYC on
Thursday the lip chin movement is all
about doing things on your own terms and
for you whatever makes you happy what
you doing once your secret you wake up
every morning and you have a positive
out looking i like i love to work out i
love to just like that's my selfish
times you've got to be a little selfish
I guess it's he doesn't 16 year for you
to be a little selfish what I've been on
my workout path for like three years
it's my lifestyle I don't want it to
just be 2016 I want to be feel like the
rest of my life I just want that to be
my routine that I wake up and I go to
the gym I work on fitness and just
healthy like even your mental you have
to practice that you have to that's a
workout in itself I think is making sure
that you're like I constantly am aware
that I want to be positive today I want
to be a kind / center